Let's see who else is holding.
How about the five zero nine area code?
I'd love to hear from our caller.
And five zero nine.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Five zero nine.
I can hear some background noise there, I
don't know if you're aware I'm talking to
you.
Hello.
Yes, that's you.
Well, yes, you.
From overnight, five oh nine, yeah.
Oh, wow.
It caught me off guard.
Yeah, I was just curious.
I just listened to send your package updates
from the website Hussle Bitch, and he'll say,
I'm sorry.
I don't understand.
I don't understand a word you're saying.
It sounds like you're coming to me from underneath
a towel.
What you listen to what now is a stimulus
Web site update and a Web site called Hucko
Bitch.
And I was just curious because you said that
the feds are dumping a lot of the stimulus
money into the stock market to raise the stock
market.
But right on that, which is no, Stephen, I
can't pronounce his last name.
This is a Web site called Hussle Bitch.
Yeah.
And he just stimulus updates.
OK, and and the argument is, is that it's
bad that the government is pouring money into
the stock market or just that that's what
the government is doing.
He said he's made that there's allegations
that feds are dumping a whole lot of the stimulus
money.
He raised the stock prices up and everything
else into junk bonds.
And he also said that MACUGEN or whatever
his name is, just dump all of the stimulus
money into some of his wealthy counterparts.
Matute spins out of control.
Matu chins of right.
He's he's a loose cannon.
You never know what Macugen will do, but I
guess they opened up the coffers and stuff
to keep the stock market prices up and it's
not going to the stimulus package that they
need to.
I guess they've dumping trillions into it.
Yes.
Allegations I've just heard.
I just wondered if you've heard anything about
a coup.
Yes.
So certainly there are multiple ways in which
stimulus money is used to prop up stock market
prices.
That that's absolutely happening.
Now, the junk bonds, specific arguments that
you're talking about.
I'm less familiar with, but I don't know the
website you're referring to.
I don't know exactly what the allegations
that are being made are.
But early, if you go back to my tweets at
the very start of this entire stimulus, one
of the things I was tweeting about was how
the stimulus is being used to artificially
prop up the stock market so that that passes
the sniff test for me.
And then the other thing is with Pelosi doing
what she's doing now.
That was kind of a really angry at her.
But after listening to that stuff, I don't
know.
She's right.
No, not it's not.
Hold on a second.
You're talking.
What specifically are you referring to that
Nancy Pelosi did?
Well, between the arguments and stuff between
them and the Republicans, the stuff about
the stimulus packages and stuff, I was kind
of getting angry at her for not, you know,
getting something forward and everything else.
Yeah.
And now I'm kind of going, well, maybe she
has a good idea.
I'm not doing this because of what they're
doing over in the Republican side.
Right.
What state do you vote?
I'm curious.
Washington, Washington State.
Spokane, Washington.
All right.
Very good.
OK.
I really appreciate the call.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Like I said, if you could get more information
out that for me so I could be more important.
I will.
I'm going to look into that.
Thank you.
All right.
Thanks for your time.
Take care.